[Applause]
i want to still do steroids
okay yeah same so what what are we doing
here how do we just do the safest amount
of steroids
i don't understand why people want
anything else we can jump out of the
plane
or peptide whatever they're [ __ ] i'm
gonna call them all steroids talk about
peptides
ped i want to do pd's i just want the
safe amount of pds we can do tons of
dangerous things in a safe way we can
jump out of planes in a safe way
we'll go skiing we can drive cars in a
safe way there's all these different
ways to do things safe right i would
like to do
this in a very safe way what is the
little bit amount where i can do it
i can have vitamin c all five vitamins
in my pocket right unregulated
unregulated vitamin c look at that i
mean wow tylenol
plow oh give me one give me one i gotta
get my backs today so i gotta take these
i gotta get my second backs i'm allowed
to take i'm allowed to get vaccines but
i can't get peptides
uh not controlled by the government what
is not controlled by the government
peptides
why does the government not want us to
be strong are they worried they will
take over the [ __ ] capital why don't
you give the military
steroids uh i don't know if they do but
i
know in certain circles they're looking
the other way
but like why shouldn't he's up you got
to be they should be giving them
every single time yeah like a chicken on
a farm just like i mean give it to
captain america
that [ __ ] worked out right that's yeah
to be in the army there's our captain
juice juice juice put them on the juice
okay so let's say no
real talk let's stay on the subject here
yes peptides safe amount how we do this
no idea
know enough how to dose it safely just
start with a little
and then just ramp up then what about
collagen peptides is that the same thing
collagen peptides like the stuff you get
from whole foods yeah that's yeah what
does that girl do that that's
what is that he's talking apples and
i've been drinking it makes my hair
super strong and stretchy yeah
no what about pre-workout and creatine
what does that do what about pre-column
have you ever tried that
which one of these should i say pure
test right that's pure testosterone what
if we just shoot
ropes right into our mouth yeah what if
we shoot roads is that why gay news are
so strong
yes it is that's why they're in great
shape gay guys are in great shape and
sore [ __ ]
[ __ ] are in great oral and injecting
points
anti-wasting drugs to aids vision wait
what was that about aids
no no it's just like not to like i'm not
talking about other people's [ __ ] i'm
telling we shoot it right up the air
like a [ __ ] kim kardashian paper
magazine cover
and then we catch it right in our mouths
it's whatever you do behind closed doors
it's your i'll do it right now
okay i don't give a flying [ __ ] don't
hog it
yeah i think to your point that's
probably a better not a better
conversation but like that's a more
readily available performance-enhancing
drug that works with minimal side
effects yeah
creatine has been around for 30 years in
research and that's like
but that [ __ ] don't make you chiseled it
just gets you kind of bloated it fills
your [ __ ] with water you want to look
like brad pitt we don't want to look
like the strong man we don't want to
look like the guy chasing around
[ __ ] pop pits breakfast's not banging
gear though
oh get out of here oh he's way too small
grandpa is doing something
he was doing some [ __ ] [ __ ] fight
club bro yeah but no definitely not
fight club that was geared
once upon a time he was built like him
bro
here's billy benoitta bennett is
probably on a gear dude oh man
they're on the game he's on the gear
jack he's just thin
no he's on the gear dude i saw him
[ __ ] shooting up gear dude
that's all the [ __ ] take out his
needle
report he's naming names here he's like
jose conseco
he was having hgh man he's on hgh he was
on an heh peptide when i saw him dude
yeah he was and he was super aggro about
it dude he was [ __ ]
aggro that guy does not seem like he's
ever been aggravated
just wait and see just wait and see dude
you heard it here first it's the
exclusive so
you say take creatine get some extra
lifts out of your workout and then
creatine caffeine
whoa whoa whoa whoa what do you mean
about caffeine this is i think
performance-enhancing drugs when we
start to talk
sports the the only get sexy the
quickest
the elephant in the room with
performance and drugs and this is i
think inadvertently gonna
help probably more than any sort of
legal illicit drug
the performance enhancing drug that i
think people need to start talking about
in professional sports
is adderall is concerta
like there's it's said in the end in the
nf or sorry the major league baseball
oh wow [ __ ] nice adderall that's pd
that's what i do played the angle off
the screen that was incredible that's a
9-0 not a 9 11.
he's right here oh come on what's wrong
no what is it a 7-eleven it's right here
let's have a dead split
[Laughter]
oh god okay that was a 7-10 split but
yeah so i think in professional sports
the thing that people aren't talking
about is
that an adderall being a well i mean
it's a performance-enhancing drug but
it's cognitive
oh it's so great i love it it's i mean
that you want to talk long-term side
effects i mean you are just taking i
took the out
i took adderall the other day and fought
with my girl dude we had like a long
argument and i knew it and
she got destroyed i was so locked in and
focused she's trying to cover her little
arguments and my brain is working a
thousand miles per hour dude it was like
a beautiful mind i was seeing
little [ __ ] algorithms and [ __ ] pop
up in the size it's like oh body slam
over and over again
i believe it yeah it's well i mean so
there's the
major league baseball is said to be the
three a's alcohol ambien and adderall
ambien gets you night night right yeah
you need to go night when you're taking
meth
i gave her some of that the next time we
were gonna fight and then that was the
best thing i ever did
he's taking the adderall she takes the
abby just yelling at her
it's just over dude yeah but like that's
that i think is where
people aren't paying attention to and
this is almost becoming a sideshow
like i think steroids now like that
steroid categorization of anabolic and
androgenic yeah
that's kind of old hat i think moving
into the peptide route insulin growth
hormone much more difficult to test for
and now the peptides we don't really
know
what they are not necessary we don't
know what they are but they're so new
that we don't know what to do with them
and then i think the frontier
furthermore to that is
is looking more to like the nootropic
route which is like a very
generalized like nutraceuticals whole
foods term like these are
very harsh drugs they're stimulants
essentially like they're literally if
you get a prescription in canada
for adderall it says on the capsule m
amphetamine it's like that's what it is
i mean this is where i'm really
stretching on my understanding of this
stuff but it is a derivative or
very similar to what we would know is
math right it's good math but how are
those white people so unproductive
the method that switch in that compound
is that takes you from adderall to like
smoking out of life bulbs like
it's like hodgkin's it's a good
hodgkin's right
yeah so that's where i think the
performance enhancing world isn't
looking
and that's where i think a lot of the
benefit is coming from like if i gotta
hit
home runs and this guy's randy johnson
six foot nine he's throwing 104 off the
mound at 60 feet away by the time that
ball leaves his arm i got point
two hundredths of a second that extra
focus is huge oh
man absolutely that's limitless bro
that's yeah you're literally bradley
i've heard uh adderall feels like the
limitless drug
yeah you've never tried it yeah no i
would love it too much
i i would do it once a month and then to
the point it's like this can't be good
for me
but i get angry on adderall yeah really
yeah yeah
i see i just agree he gets an
androgynous aggro i get androgenous
androgenic yeah i get
his ball shrink up and he gets
unreasonable my balls don't shrink up
actually
really yeah i was looking at my balls to
get bloated no but like
no it's just regular balls but my sexual
appetite is not very high well
actual appetite is known to go down that
also i have to like remind myself to
set timers i would do that yeah i was
taking out or i'll get some work done or
something
yeah get [ __ ] shredded yes well yeah
but then you're headed down the mat then
just take math they get shredded
yeah but then your teeth fall out yeah
yeah yeah but give me the
adderall of hgh give me the adderall of
testosterone give me the adderall give
me the safe version of it that's it
that's that's them
oh so they're all good i'm only getting
bored the [ __ ] are you talking about
more dangerous from there yeah like
testosterone is kind of like this very
blanket cnn term
like afternoon special ben affleck kind
of raging out it's like
there are so many more designers like if
you just look at any banned substance
list right that's a good place to start
yeah
you're gonna see like so many chemical
compound names that you've never seen
before
yeah it's like the the lay person who
doesn't necessarily have to worry about
and this is something that when you deal
with professional athletes it's like
hey this supplement company is sending
me this pre-workout
and it's like you got to get real
familiar with a lot of chemical names
because there could be something in
there
that's on the label or more often the
case not on the label
it's like you know you want to make sure
that your players are protected yeah
they can't just be haphazardly going
into taking anything
because it's like there's not just
testosterone it's not like the we're
coming for your testosterone test
like they're working on them enough like
it's the cure for cancer
can they test uh can they test for
adderall
um i don't know because i don't know the
half-life of it because they know like
there's like
short release or extended release versus
not but i don't know if there's any sort
of like metabolite or fat storage
property to it that would leave it in
your system for longer
right um it'd be interesting and here's
the thing
at the end of the day someone got pops
and then they said
that they were taking adderall so like
the adderall had something else in it or
the adderall elicited some other
reaction that they got popped for and
they were like no i take adderall that's
what it is
or maybe it was a a boner pill
it wasn't a boxer that got popped and
was like no was it canelo oh something i
i do remember this happening
and now they said it was bad meat or
something like that oh yeah the bad
thing is hilarious like you're not
looking at the absolute best meat for
the the guy who's worth 300 million
dollars if they
every time an athlete gets popped
they're dead to rights
but they still they go down swing go
down swinging bro that's your worst
got it worse it wasn't me the guy was
like oh it was horse meat the other guy
at the olympics was saying like oh no i
drank like eight beers and like had an
orgy with like seven broads like the
night before it's like no you didn't
but that's what my testosterone was so
high i was laying pipe all night it's
like
no it's like there's nothing better than
a really bad drug pop excuse
you